scientifically is true uh women women
are more emotional so in a work
environment men probably could handle
that a little bit better than women
could scientifically it's true so that
it just makes sense it just makes sense
everything
I well we Define if you define the word
it's when you have hate towards women
when Andrew Tate says that a lot of
women that watch it just are shape just
like you said they don't even know what
the word misogyny means
as your porn and sex addiction affected
your studies work marriage and family
relationship are you stuck with feelings
of guilt shame remorse and despair or
has your addiction progressed from
pornography to Zena well we're here to
tell you you're not alone I test Kia is
the place where Muslim males and females
struggling with pornography addictions
can find recovery and freedom
brothers and sisters and dear friends so
the reason I'm doing this specific video
with the sisters as you can see let me
centralize myself oh there we go
um I had a message some some sister
messaged me and she seemed very very
disturbed like it's as if her Iman was
on the line
and she really really expressed I asked
her to join as well I don't know if she
I don't think she is going to but she
was very distressed she was like we feel
let down by our brothers
and there was a lot of things she said I
can't remember this she was saying that
there's certain things that Andrew Tate
said before
um so she was very surprised how the
brothers just embraced him and they're
happy over it so I thought to myself
any believer who's Iman has been shaken
whatever it may be even if some people
watching this and be like oh it's your
typical feminist to me I take it
seriously whatever it is I think it's
important and I always on my channel try
to have the sisters to have their say
for them to come and open up to us as
well so what I was going to say is
inshallah that's why I invited you guys
to come on inshallah so I want to try to
get straight into it
I don't know how many of you guys are
I'm not gonna say Pro or against but
what is your opinions of Andrew Tate and
what is your opinion like for example
him coming to Islam please you know only
time will tell how he will use Islam and
how it will refine him inshallah that's
what you know none of us are going to be
the judge of that and we can we can only
tell from observation as time goes on
but yes it's definitely something that
from experience it is here to refine her
it is here to make us better that is the
whole point of it
um every single one of the sahaba where
reverts some of them came from the worst
of paths and became the best of people
um personally as a river you know if
somebody was to know me 12 years ago it
would be a completely different person
that they knew until I know what it can
do
I also know that a lot of people come to
Islam and it really doesn't do much for
them you know
um and they fall into the wrong guidance
and that kind of thing that can also
happen but my answer to anybody that has
a sort of a shaken Faith by it or
anything else like that if anything they
should just reframe the way that they're
thinking about it the sister they should
be thinking subhanallah Allah Allah is
so great that even someone like Andrew
Tate so if they really dislike him in
his past comments so much they should be
even more overwhelmed with joy that this
person you know is now going to
inshallah become better so they should
be happy they should be like right I
didn't like him hopefully now he'll
he'll be better they should be
um your faith would be it would make
more logic it would make more sense
anyway for your face to be shaken
um if Islam hadn't affected him in such
a way yeah so what do you think are the
concerns because I think a lot of
sisters feel felt maybe threatened by
him but now that he's a Muslim they're
like oh my gosh like you know our
husbands or our brothers or cousins are
already you know like kind of whatever
influenced by him but now he's a Muslim
so the thing is do you think there's
some kind of a fear where he's like this
is what I sense I sense as if our
sisters like and I might be wrong our
sisters be feminists are not feminists
they have this genuine concern of
traditional men waking up like well hold
on a second like well what's going on
here like it's as if like I feel as if
they there is some kind of the the the
Western World and feminism and what's
the agenda side is pushing it's made men
and not to feel wanting to be a man like
they are afraid to be a man and Jordan
talks about this do you think this is
where it's coming from where the sisters
are just terrified of
like a man who's got the Traditional
Values you know like being the maintain
and protector and and the the our
scissors are kind of brainwashed into
this whole you know maybe the career
feminism equality do you think that
plays a role
yeah
yeah that's that was actually
subhanallah one of the first things that
I wanted to say um I remember there was
a video and I'm sure you guys might have
seen this where this guy he goes around
and he asks women if they know who
Andrew Tate is and whether they like him
or not and most of them were like no we
don't right and then he asked them why
and they couldn't really you know come
up with a reason why what did he say
what did he do right and so what I found
is that they're not so worried really
with what he says but rather what
triggers them is the fact that he is
empowering men he came with a movement
that is empowering masculinity manual
manhood and he's saying there's nothing
wrong with masculinity and a lot of men
are resonating with that because for a
long time they've been emasculated
and so now you have and that's why a lot
of women who
they don't have a problem with
traditional men a lot of women who are
not prescribing to these Western isms
they don't really have a problem with
him convert um we've been conversion to
Islam
right and so they're coming in they're
understanding why he converted to
Islamic understanding what his
perspective is and whatever he said
before even before they understand the
perspective that he's coming from a lot
of the people that did have a problem
and it's not only feminists it's just
it's liberals in general a lot of these
people had a problem with Andrew Tate
even before he converted to Islam and so
a lot of the Muslims who prescribe to
these isms not only men I mean not only
women who prescribe to feminism but even
some men a lot of the people who had a
problem with Andrew take converting to
Islam it's because of their
prescription towards liberalism and
because of this they are not able to
really understand the effects of
emasculation of feminism why because
liberalism of which feminism stems from
are all rooted in individualism these
people are obsessed with themselves and
when you are so obsessed with yourself
right which is what individualism is you
don't really have the time to observe
Society to care about what's going on to
everybody else and to
critically and logically put aside your
emotions and just analyze what's going
on so a lot of the women right who
actually accept it because we know that
the men most of them were happy with
Andrew Tate's conversion right the women
who were it's because they do not
prescribe to individuals
and you won't hear them saying we're
families and so the woman that did have
a problem they were the woman who
basically they are individualists they
don't understand where he's coming from
yeah I saw that I saw that video as well
and it just seems like that it's like
when someone is vilified other people
just follow like sheep like they're like
okay why is this guy that nobody asks
why how what was it about there is no
evidence would you see a lot of emotions
you know
um and and like sisters can be quite
emotional yeah unless some people might
even discernment oh you're misogynistic
oh look how you how dare you know they
can be there it's it's you know I'm not
saying every single one of them there's
exceptions to rule but they can have
their moments when they're emotional but
the thing is here is that like for
example let's go to like let's say
sister Imani so or and the rest is well
inshallah that what do you think like
the system mentioned as well what other
concerns do you think these sisters have
what is their problem because I feel as
if what she said is right that they are
afraid that men are you know men have
been emasculated and now they are
embracing that and they're like hold on
a second I've been sleeping all this
time and I feel as if the Muslim females
not all of them they see that as a
direct threat do you agree do you think
that's where this sentiment is coming
from
um yeah I can say something I agree with
the sister I think that it is mainly
um the women in the religion and outside
the religion that you know ascribed to
these isms like you say
um and it all comes down to
individualism and it all comes down to
the fact that they're not describing
themselves to Islam holistically
um and in ISM instead so I do get that
and then I think there's also a small
crossover of women who are a little bit
confused so although they may be quite
traditionalist in in themselves I think
you were right in saying that maybe
there are some sisters who have heard
you know that he's um
very heard things about him and whatnot
they're not quite sure what he said they
might be married and they're worried
that their husbands are going to you
know take on these um these these traits
that they've heard which may or may not
be true
um and it may just be something and
nothing for those women they may be
actually you know if they were to listen
to what he's saying they may not
disagree as much as they thought I think
there's a small percentage of women who
are just a bit confused and they think
what he's saying is worse than what it
is as well thing is is that his delivery
pre-islam you know it was quite extreme
and I think that was like 90 of the
issue
um but now that he's he's Muslim
hopefully inshallah he'll have that
guidance on how to address people and
things you know it can be refined and
maybe there are a small cross-section of
women who
um aren't so far into the feminism and
the isms but inshallah they'll just see
that actually no he's got quite a Muslim
fitra about him to an extent it just
needs to be molded refined a little bit
okay so so that's interesting
um like you said that subhanallah
so we've got two people here Bako and
safwan
um are these can you guys unmute
yourself
and yes so is it sister yes hello yeah
do you so what's your stance on Andrew
are you more proud do you have concerns
do you have any concerns with Andrew
Tate like before now and like
and what is the concerns of the other
sisters like you know why are females so
it's a Muslim women are very like you
know upset about you know himself
uh thank you for adding me in
um the only thing that um I would like
to say is that Andrew Tate has had a bit
of a harsh delivery before
um in the past he speaks he speaks his
mind he says things that he truly
believes but his delivery was a little
bit harsh no if I'm Pro or against
Andrew Tate
I am 100 agreeing with let's say 99.9 of
the things that he says because he is
quite accurate he might say it in a very
harsh way he might say it in a way that
might offend somebody but
in order to be able to think you have to
be able to offend people sometimes as
well when you have to be able to listen
for example agitate use it like if I'm
saying is used words like you know some
sort of obedience to the husband you
know so a lot of people this might be
one of the issues like you know a lot of
Muslim sisters like we've I've been in
the dial for 10 years speaking they
don't like that word when it comes to
obedience like do you think these are
like trigger words like when people hear
it like in general to to everyone like
maybe open it to everyone inshallah you
guys unmute yourself I think it was um's
audio so I want to make it open
discussion inshallah in a nutshell for
example as as female I tend to um within
your nature and I think of course all
them all the sisters watching within
your nature for example you know when
you have a child yeah I don't know yes
does anybody have kids here
anybody have children
okay if you guys you know don't well you
know when you have a child you tend to
like the fact that they depend on you
you love the fact that they need you you
want to give them that love you want
them you want to protect them and you
want to nurture them you want to look
off them and you love that like my wife
always says the fact that our child
depends on her like that you know she
finds that amazing
us men we are the same way we love the
fact that our partners depend on us now
dependence doesn't mean in the wrong way
where I have these strings and I will do
whatever I like with you and if you
don't and I'll cut one of the strings
the thing is here is that we as men just
as you with your child we love the fact
that our wives depend on us and we're
the providers and protectors and carers
so to go to Sister Ami Amina and sister
Imani and sister Zahra just open this
question
um
do you think like I said before that is
one of the issues they have when it
comes to a man's role as you know being
obedient to him now that are there sugar
words that Undertaker is used that's
caused this animosity towards him
self I think the most triggering thing
was when he once mentioned that after a
marriage when the father father like
walks the bride to the you know to the
groom if the woman belongs to him and
the word belongs to him was I think
quite triggering for a lot of women but
I think he also clarified today uh in in
the podcast with Muhammad hijab um that
he meant that belonging to the man means
that the man is now
um in charge of taking care of the woman
and providing for her and like giving
her a safe home safe environment but
instead in social media our mainstream
media it was portrayed as if he was
saying that a woman is now his property
and he can tell her or anything like
this so it was quite uh taken into the
extreme although I think that even
clarified his stance there
and I think this is also generally not
only in Android Tates
um scenario now but in general
mainstream media always tells that um
I'm sorry guys my collection is actually
awful I'm in the middle of a town center
and uh I don't think there's a massive
mass of life
okay
no no problem if there's I'm going to
come to you next if there's quickly
something you just want to add on uh Aki
before you go
um so I just finished your point as soon
as a man is going to adapt the
traditional masculine role uh it's
called Mac toxic masculinity although I
don't I think um there isn't really the
term toxic masculinity or toxic uh
femininity I think these are just made
of words so Jordan Peterson says for
example there's toxic masculinity but
why is it not toxic femininity toxic is
toxic why is it toxic only connected to
masculinity you know yeah because these
days like for example I know many cases
of Brothers who have been forced accused
of rape who have been forced accused of
beating their wives
they've been they're going through this
stuff and you can see even like for
example I hear stories of women
physically trying to attack their
husbands so why isn't that toxic
femininity so why is toxic only
connected to the to masculinity which is
the point that you made if one
understands essentially what toxic what
musculinity is there is no such thing as
as toxicity because everything that they
categorize right as masculinity is
something that actually goes as toxic
masculinity something that goes against
masculinity because masculinity is a
part of the characteristics of
masculinity is that a man wants to
protect who wants to provide he wants to
take care he wants to be a leader he has
these all these positive characteristics
that's masculinity and so when a man
does something that opposes any of this
you can't say that that's toxic
masculinity what's toxic about that is
the lack of masculinity and that's also
one of the reasons why today there's a
lot of crimes against women because
feminism emasculated men it told them
that masculinity is wrong and now
they're emasculated they don't have
masculinity anymore and so they're doing
all of these things and instead of us
recognizing that it's because of
emasculation it's because these men are
lacking their masculinity and we need to
go back to that we're saying no it's
toxic masculinity
it's like a Band-Aid that they're
putting on Top This is it's as good as
me telling a woman that she cannot be
feminine if you're feminine if if you
um explore your feminine side to
yourself you are toxic feminine and
you're like well okay what do I become
then so if I cannot become a man if I'm
scared to be like you know what in my
household I'm the leader yeah and let me
let me actually very clear I am the
leader in my household yeah what does
that mean by leader but I go and beat my
wife about hey I'm beat up let me let me
start punching you and you know if you
don't do this yeah where's my food my
food is late too salty okay slap I mean
I don't know what goes through people's
minds yeah
um is that leader means what at the end
of the day there can't be two leaders in
the household yeah there has to be one
leader does that mean I don't take my
wife's decisions of course I do today I
plan the day and by the way women like
to be planned you know ahead you know
the fact that the man is taking that
leading role but if my wife comes and
says you know instead of eating there
should we go here that's a brilliant
idea actually I'm before that let's go
and do that so it's it's this notion
that obedience being the leader be in
the provider somehow is a direct threat
oh my gosh do you think that's the case
it's the Imani and sister Amino
um no I I personally think things like
50 50 is is wrong it's wrong and I
wouldn't like to do that
but women can't expect to not go 50 50
and then think I should not be obedient
to my husband I shouldn't respect my
husband you can't eat happy cake and eat
there needs to be some level of fairness
it's not to do with equality it's to do
with equity
the fact of the matter is that a lot of
women not wanting traditional men it's
women wanting wanting Modern Men meant
that want to go 50 50 meant that I don't
know how to be in charge
and men that would
obey the wife more than the wife would
obey the man it's it's it's it's it's
how it's how men want it to be more
modernized it's just how it's just how
times are changing now and you see
you see people allowing certain things
that shouldn't be allowed like in
schools for example it's just it's just
how women think oh
um this is something that's wrong women
shouldn't
have to obey the man at all because
women should be obeyed too does that I
mean do you believe that when it comes
to like what is it that for example that
you said you don't want it 50 50. yeah
okay and we believe that's that's that's
Islam the thing is we see like women
want traditional men but they don't want
to be traditional women so they're like
yeah I want this this this and this okay
good but these men want these and
they're like oh no but I don't want to
be what am I say what do you mean like
you want this but you don't want to be
so traditional men want traditional
women so like you said obedience for
example someone might come and said
you're just brainwashed you're a woman
you're a self-hating woman you know so
when you say for example like a man
should be obeyed like let me put it like
this and tell me if I'm wrong yeah at
the end of the day a man's job is not
easy neither is a woman's a woman has
like there's things that a woman can do
that I can't do and there's things I can
a woman cannot do and we need to
we're a team uh together if we both had
the equal things if I didn't rely on my
wife my wife didn't rely on me how would
we even be a team do you get what I'm
trying to say it's like if I had a
specific business where I'm selling
something like Andrew said this in this
video he said if I'm an accountant and
then you have a tailor and if you say to
the tailor you know what you do half the
accounting and they get the tailor to do
and you do half the tailoring he's an
expert in his field I'm an expert in my
field we work together and we make a
company like he said he did it very well
you know so the thing is that it should
be like that but it's as if the sisters
are like no you know we want to be equal
and it's like why is your success bar
meant in the first way it's
self-defeating I want to be why do you
want to be like a man so sister Imani
can can we just have you must have even
a bit quiet but yeah everyone's got
really good reviews I agree with pretty
much everything I'm glad that it's it's
to be honest it would have been more fun
if there was someone disagreeing with us
but we're pretty much on the same page
alhamdulillah which is also really good
in the same page because I'll be honest
with you it's very interesting because
it shows that there are Muslim woman out
there who do not hate Andrew Tate yes
there are things I still have questions
to to what you're saying and this is
just
um a Learning lesson for myself if
anything
um and I understand completely where
you're coming from that there are some
women out there who are not willing to
fulfill their traditionalist side of
things
um and they may want to have their cake
and eat it too
um me personally I don't think I'm
inshallah gonna have that issue when I
get married but
it would be nice to know what are some
of those things that men want women to
come back to what is it that they feel
when we generalize women and say they
don't want to do these things obviously
not us alhamdulillah but some women out
there what what are these things
um there's the obvious ones like you
know demanding to go out and work when
they when you know when their husband
doesn't want them to
you know I can show you like as a
traditional man if you're asking the
question I can list the things that we
want
yeah yeah sometimes it's it's good to
know that as well yeah I'll be honest
with you number one for example I want
to be like for example the provider I
believe in a relationship if the woman
is a provider it will not work out now
this doesn't mean a woman cannot have a
job of course you can have a job if my
wife wanted to go do a part-time job
because she wants to I have no problem
that money is hers she can do whatever
she likes with it but I will never allow
her to pay for the rent the shopping
petrol whatever it may be I will say to
her I don't give you a multi-millionaire
these are the things I pay for I don't
believe in relationship will work
because a man for example will feel very
insulted if one day a little argument
happens and she goes well who pays for
the bill that is for a man that's like
as good as punching him never once
either because he feels like he wants to
be the maintainer and protector just as
he has that towards her child she loves
the fact that she needs to provide for
him number two people understand that
and my my question is I mean
alhamdulillah that's like you know dream
come true you don't have to work
so my my perspective is I don't I just
don't understand
you know where this uh pool of women are
coming from when it comes to these
things my my I mean maybe also I it's
hard to speak on it because I've never
been married and I'm not married yet so
maybe you know inshallah I'll have to
deal with these difficulties myself but
objectively and looking inward it just
looks like maybe they don't know how
good it can be
like how good they could actually have
it and it's what it is a sister there's
a book called miseducation of woman by
James Tudy I recommend you guys to read
here it just talks about how the women
have been brainwashed into this whole
career mindset I I speak to like
individual sisters Etc where they don't
feel complete like if they have a child
and they bring the child at home they
feel like they are worthless I have to
have a career and as men I don't have no
criteria when I was looking for my
partner I don't care if she was a
Dustbin collector I don't care if she
was wiping the windows I don't care what
she it's irrelevant her career has zero
to do with my decision factor I do not
look and be like because because women
tend to look at a man's future and be
like okay I want a man who's strong
who's working who's doing something with
his life we as men we don't look for a
woman with a career I'll be honest with
you I don't I don't look for one with a
career personally as men most
traditional men they don't want that
they just look for a wife who can be
their companion you know that is a
traditional woman for example if a man
says to his wife you know what I don't
like you wearing lipstick I don't want
to talk about lipstick misogyny what do
you mean misogyny what do you mean
misogyny if I if I am protecting
maintaining if I'm walking down the road
and somebody comes with a knife and
trying to attack my wife I'm gonna have
to put my life on the line meaning I am
willing to die for you literally I am
willing to die for you if I'm in a ship
imagine the Titanic here let's make this
a bit more romantic yeah and me and my
wife are on it I'm going to be sending
my wife and the kids I'm going to be
taking that risk off you know what you
guys are safe so if a man is willing to
go down that route where he's trying to
protect and trying to provide and if a
thief comes knocks on the door when
she's scared like there's certain things
I'll never let my wife out for example
once my wife took out the bin and I
think I was I was I think I was in like
I can't remember I was doing something I
didn't notice and I was really upset I
said look I don't look at the time it's
dangerous out there I don't like I tell
her I'll take the men out that's my job
yeah don't ever feel like you know you
have to do stuff like that so the thing
is why because I care about her I don't
want like something so simple like that
it should be my duty so if that's the
case what is wrong with us men asking
for obedience meaning that if I'm doing
all of these because I care and love you
not because I want to control you and
I'm insecure and I'm toxic why is it
hard for sisters to be like you know
what
yeah
can I say one more thing sorry I know
I'd like kind of dominated now recently
as well
I agree I agree with all of that as well
um and I think that
um if I was to you know play the other
side for a minute try and put myself in
the mind of these sisters you have these
worries these concerns
um I would say that my only fear or um
concern going forward would be the fact
that there are also a group of men I
don't know the size whether it's small
or big but there are a group of men who
who do do it on the other way where they
expect The Obedience and they expect
everything else but then they don't
provide so they you know and then they
don't do these things and then women are
forced into poverty in situations where
you know either they defy their husband
and you know go through some of the
situation or whatever not even poverty
but they're forced into situations where
they're always leading anyway the
manager is very you know relaxed he's
like yeah don't worry you make the
decision and she's just like I don't
want to make decisions but we have kids
to feed and you know schools to pick and
things like that so we need to talk we
need to call those Brothers out and we
do like me yeah of course I know it
comes to me and says there's this
potential I'm getting to know him Etc
but instead I need to be contributing
towards the rent outside yeah like I
don't know but it's just you know
um maybe if that's what I'm saying I'm
just trying to put myself in the in
their shoes in their mind maybe because
of this small group of people or large
group of people it's then become a
um a coping mechanism and a barrier
they're kind of like no well no one's
going to take the mick out of me like
that I have to be self-sufficient and so
they put up this this wall believing
that no matter every man is going to use
that in this toxic way for you to use
because they put a Band-Aid on the
problem yeah they're not understanding
then it would be fine so that's valid is
that the incompetence of men are leading
women to be insecure that they are now
looking for alternatives to provide
because then they're not seeing the
future with this husband so in that
instance I'll say you know what look I
I'm with you guys if a man is making you
feel insecure and he's not protecting
and providing and he's not even when it
comes to like monster and respect Etc
how he's disrespecting you he's abusing
you he's maybe hitting you and all this
kind of stuff and on top of that once
obedience we are not talking about a man
like that let me be a bit more
commercial like Hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him who said that
if I was to ask and this some sisters
might hear this and be like whoa yeah if
I was to ask anyone to bow down to
anyone it would be the wife to the
husband bow down you know frustration
that we go into he said if it wasn't out
I would ask the wife to bow down to the
husband now the husband that we're
talking about when we hear these kind of
hadiths is like oh my gosh my husband
who hits me who beats me doesn't provide
for me no when did the prophet talk
about him the prophet saws is talking
about a man who is good to his family
who's good to his kids who is protecting
who provides who loves his wife who's
soft with his wife who provides for his
wife and does so many things and he's
because going out there and working or
if a war happens putting a life on the
line these are Big sacrifices so Allah
and his Messengers acknowledging the
Gratitude to that kind of man but a lot
of systems they tend to get they think
this this husband that they may have or
their father and they like what might
what the prophet wants me to bow down
and the funny thing is going back to
Andrew Tate is that um see these
stipulations that you're saying that you
know well the stipulations are in place
for the man as well you know we're not
just asking for blind obedience he I
believe that even though he delivered it
kind of kind of harshly he also made the
stipulation he would always say if a man
is going to do this then a woman should
do this and he would provide the
stipulation I didn't see many videos
where he was saying women should do this
and women it was always if a man is
doing this so I feel like coming back to
him because you know that's the point
you know
look he's saying things where he's like
okay he's telling the men to be real men
and that's good because what that's
doing is like we spoke about if men are
real men a woman would not feel insecure
or wanted to find a career job to
provide because the men so if Andrew
Tate is saying be a man and this how to
be a man what's wrong with that that's
going to defeat the whole thing of okay
this is how men should be and if you're
like this which is good yeah there's
some stuff he said before which is a new
beginning point
to be a real man if that's the case that
should be embraced by our sisters
foreign
you know one thing I wanted to mention
is um
so the the
when they say that they we have an
exception these bad men they are the
exceptions to the rules right now the
reason why many sisters
you guys can hear an echo
no we can hear you okay good so the
reason why many sisters feel so
um insecure it's because number it's not
only because of these men that's the
idea that's being pushed to them but
it's really because they're being told
that and that their value is weighed
either in the level of to in relation to
man or in terms of money
you know if you could be a mother you
can have children you can have all of
that you can have many children
masha'allah your family is all healthy
and well but Society will not praise you
for that
the way that they'd praise you if you're
doing something out in society in a
career or something like that because
they've now made that financial status
that's what you that's what your value
is weighed in until you do everything a
man can do then you're you're worthless
so everything to do with femininity
motherhood everything to do with us
being a woman is being degraded
yes and one of the reasons and the
reason why this this is this has become
so prevalent is because and it's one of
the this is why I say all isms are
interconnected right we have feminism
here and it's interconnected to
secularism why
because when they took a lot out of the
equation they took God they made a
secular society they just got out of the
equation now they have to set the
standard by which everybody would now
have to follow the standard so what do
they put in the standard they put them
on they put the masculine and so
everything else would be inferior in
front of Allah in our distinctiveness
both men and women are equal both the
masculine and The Feminine are equal in
our distinctiveness so femininity it's
different from masculinity but the value
is the same our significance in society
is the same what happens when you take a
lot of the equation
what has put us on that same level of
significance is gone
so then now what the masculine
proceeds takes the place and now you
have femininity and everything else
which has to it's not on the same level
anymore so now until you become the
standard which is now the man you have
to provide you have to work you have to
do this you have to do that and so you
become that you will feel inferior
and Society will not praise you for that
exactly and so that's what happened now
with that's how secularism is
interconnected to feminism they don't
have Allah to put them all on the same
level
yeah I think sister what really uh just
pointed out a lot of things that were
really like um
um had to be said and made clear and
just so one point that I wanted to add I
mean uh it's just an argument but I
would even argue that the woman has been
made just a product of the economy I
mean 100 years ago women weren't even
working they were at home and were
Homemakers right but slowly until now I
mean until today
every every other woman is a working
woman and is being taken out of this
home bro the Homemaker role and I think
the main I mean if you think from the
other side what is the advantage
from let's say these people we always
say they but we don't really know who
they are but I think the one point
what's really important to
um like um look at is that we're just
another like we're just being added to
the people who pay tax right so if one
man is working at one in one house he's
providing for the home and he's one man
that's paying taxes right but if the
woman or the wife is main is being like
made to go to work and then the children
as soon as they are old enough everyone
either even if it's a boy or a girl
everyone goes to work more taxpayers I
mean this is one argument that I haven't
been thinking about but lately I just
came across this and it really it really
clicked and it makes a lot of sense when
we're in these discussions exactly and
it will increase the value of the demand
that's working because if women stay at
home then you there's more demand for
workers that it will increase the value
of the man and that man will provide
because the value would increase
um
it decreases the wages and the education
system see now you get the children into
the education system as quickly as
possible and the education system
actually benefits the corporate world so
you get the children into the schools as
quick as possible because both the man
and the women are out in the workforce
and then now because you have more
people working for you the jobs are less
in demand you lower the wages
and then double the taxes now you have
the whole population out into the site
so those are the three advantages you
see that's how capitalism is now related
to feminism and this is why I say all
isms are interconnected I think some of
the things that sisters are also annoyed
about is how Andrew Tates said some
things like
um women don't know how to handle their
emotion
they are emotional and all of that
scientifically is true uh women women
are more emotional so in a work
environment men probably could handle
that a little bit better than women
could scientifically it's true so that
it just makes sense it just makes sense
everything
I well it's importantly defined if you
define the word it's when you have hate
towards women
when Andrew Tate says that a lot of
women that watch it just are sheep just
like you said they don't even know what
the word misogyny means so they will say
yeah yeah he's misogynistic they will
not have a clue what misogyny even means
exactly so when you ask them oh by the
way what what does misogyny even mean
they just don't know what to say they
will just freeze
um Andrew Tate hasn't really said
anything that has hate towards women
so in my opinion in my opinion it's just
it's just a lack of knowledge
yeah it is and it's just it's just
fear-mongering I just see it's what it's
I mean what they're doing is the same
with us Muslims you know when they go
and ask these you know people who don't
like us yeah they're all like this
they're like yeah okay what what does it
says
um
no they just hate us we're just like the
Muslims it's like it's just like a
female green everyone's like oh my God
you know we're scared of no I don't know
what it is have you read the book no I
don't it's just this fear Mongolian
that's been happening
um and you can you can you can see it
subhanallah
um and the study like in the book that
I'm reading miseducational woman James
Tooley he talks about there was a study
done from the 1970s how many did you
mentioned this podcast the 1990s they
interviewed about 100 000 women and you
know if you look at it they are less
happy the fact that all of you sisters
are in sync like I'll be honest with you
that the fact that you're like because
you know why you want a husband that
will protect and provide it's not the
other way of this whole career woman Etc
you can see that women are less happy in
the workplace I think 78 percent or
eight percent of women said that they
they get stressed you know they have
cycling mental psychological issues
pertaining to having to go to work they
want somebody so if you look at our
sisters or Muslim females at large as
well they generally don't want to go
work they want traditional men but the
point is also we need to be bear in mind
as well are there traditional uh men
yeah that's another issues I wish we
need to be fair as well are men men
today sadly they're not so I think it's
there's a Revival happening since
tobacco is there anything you would like
to add on before we wrap up
uh yes I fully agree with all the
sisters and what they were saying I
wanted to just add one thing to
um to the sisters as well
um the funny thing about feminism is
that it has completely Brainwashed the
entire society and has brainwashed women
into working and asking and begging to
become a man basically and fulfilling
manly and more masculine roles at the
same time hating on the same masculine
roles whenever men are are
um doing uh fulfilling those roles and
calling them toxic and the funny thing
is that men women actually don't have an
issue with the word obey uh this is
actually it is a very triggering word it
kind of it's like a Hot Topic button
it's like you turn it and everybody goes
a little bit crazy but I noticed that
most of the women especially the ones
that are working we have been
brainwashed into wanting to work and not
do anything else to be able to Value
themselves to the echo to the equality
of men uh with men they don't mind
obeying their boss they don't mind
obeying their employers absolutely
it's enslavement to obey your husband
and your children but it's empowerment
to obey your boss do you see them
absolutely absolutely it's complete
hypocrisy if your husband asks you can
you please make me a coffee
um you'll be like oh no don't you dare
I'm not your slave yeah exactly
yes of course you see that's the
hypocrisy but that's the point it's all
about
sorry sorry I'm just a bit excited here
so is that because that it just really
triggers me I'm so sorry
no it's it's absolutely true if we're
both asking people like oh yes of course
so would you like milk and sugar with
that but whenever it's your husband it's
like oh I'm not using it go do it
yourself and the boss doesn't care about
you he really doesn't care about you
he'll replace you tomorrow if you
misfire one sheet of paper or whatever
it is exactly and you know what they say
about you and loves you
you know you hear a lot of women busy
saying oh but what if um you know I have
to go and work I have to go and get a
career what if my husband dies what if I
get a divorce what if your boss fires
you
you're going to be in the same
predicament your rhythmic comes from
Allah it doesn't come through a person
that's what many women today think that
there is it comes through a person it
doesn't it it comes from a person it
comes through a person if that person
goes you're gonna get your music through
another way exactly it's like taking the
uncle over the knuckle you know like
thinking oh and the Allah provides but
it's very important because if you think
about your boss has no connection to
your kids and you as an individual yeah
he can fire you immediately your husband
will think twice because you have shared
my life with this person I love this
person we have kids so many factors that
might have prevent him from giving the
divorce and we know like most of the
games 70 or 80 of the times a woman tend
to initiate divorce anyways but the
thing is they are what you say is very
important if we reverse things and we
said you know what if if an individual
if I was married to a woman who was like
no you go do this accession she's a
career woman or whatever I'll say you
know what no problem I'm not paying for
the rent shopping nothing we're going to
have an employee employment relationship
from now on I'm gonna be paying you
hourly rate how much do you want 25
pounds an hour no problem I'm gonna be
30 pounds an hour and 30 pounds an hour
there you go you can we're going to
share the bills we're going to share
that little trip we're going to share
the guys everything we're going to share
you are now you're employed by me and I
would like coffee in the morning please
thank you very much and at 2 p.m I would
like my food please I would like a
Biryani or lasagna and I would like and
then you know what she'll be like well
hold on a second this is exactly so what
was the difference what was the
difference when it is an employer it's
like okay I have to if I don't I'm in
trouble I have three strikes but when
it's your husband I'm trying to say this
so it's very very valid so I think
that's it I don't need anything anymore
I think may Allah bless you guys well I
I always like to have sex coming on
board because I can't speak for you you
speak for yourself and I think you guys
spoken very clear facts you know
opinions you know we've talked about
things you know and once again I don't
want sisters that are watching this we
know and what we're striving for in the
tower food to be honest with you is to
get men to be minigan we know sadly a
lot of men are not men when I hear this
stuff of Brothers saying yeah I want my
wife to contribute it makes me sick she
doesn't add to that please she doesn't
need to contribute to nothing brother
and if you can't if you are even
thinking of that you're not ready for
marriage please don't look for marriage
yeah can I add to that um what um I'm
sure everybody has noticed what's
happening to society they're turning
um men into women and women into men so
women are they're joining them so fast
so masculine or just want to do work
work and go get go and get you go and
get your money says boss babe and all of
those uh girl both um uh BS that you're
seeing everywhere and men are being
celebrated for turning into women and
being more feminine and with their
feminizing men and the funny thing is
we're living in this really weird
um delusion because let's be honest
whenever the real world real life
actually hits you see what happened in
Ukraine the moment that the war started
women and children everybody go I belong
in the kitchen
let's go we have to like forget feminism
they dropped feminism like it's like
it's uh
yeah yeah they're like I want to go back
to the kitchen they're like I know you
want the kitchen
there was a transgender woman yeah and
he was literally said no no you're going
to war sorry there's no see so when
reality hits when reality is like if you
think about it how many of you sisters
if you're in a house may Allah protect
you guys and the house is on fire and
they say okay we're gonna call the
feminist five Brigade and the old woman
how many of you guys I don't I don't no
no I need mentors
a team coming to save you there's
certain things they're not going to be
able to do I mean you're gonna have to
carry a person on your shoulder yeah
okay and imagine and like you know some
people are quite heavy you know imagine
you just you're gonna die no famous
would want that I think that's it I
think we could maybe inshallah you
sisters were amazing may Allah bless
every single one of you guys may Allah
preserve you guys thanks for giving this
opportunity to have your say inshallah
and brothers and sisters who are
watching at home hope you guys benefited
from this may Allah bless all the
sisters you heard from themselves this
perception that Muslim women don't like
Andrew Tay Etc he's not perfect we're
not here to praise him let's just make
them very clear but we have a fine
balance we're not overly pleasing him
we're not here to like have a go away he
has a past like we all do forgive in
forgiving inshallah and we hope that he
has a good ending and a good life
inshallah and we're just here to talk
about those facts um is why I don't say
something quickly
just one more thing I have to say to
these sisters here I have a community a
traditional sisters and I just love what
you guys were saying and I'd love you
guys to join it's called Uh the sisters
Corner we are a network of like-minded
sisters and we want to the synagogue
probably knows us he can tell you more
about us inshallah
um but for you guys you guys can find us
on Instagram the sister's corner and I'd
love to have you guys join because I
love to get in contact with like-minded
sisters and our objective is to revive
traditional Islamic values and to
provide support
Etc so inshallah I'd love to have all of
you guys join us
inshallah sister Imani any last words
uh no just again it's been really nice
to speak to some people that are on the
same page
um I find myself having to hold my
tongue and just keep quiet in a lot of
situations and conversations going on
recently
um and yeah it was nice it was nice that
some people are on the same page and
understand but also it's nice that you
understand that you know uh not that we
agree with these sisters views but we
can understand what's planted that in
their heads and we just sympathize with
them and try and
you know encourage a different way of
thinking
which is very valid because we don't
want to dismiss these sisters that's why
I opened the plan yeah they're confused
or they're worried about something they
obviously have this fear
and we need to understand that we can't
brush it off if someone is a general
content and they're hurt that shows if
somebody's email is hurt that it's not
coming from a place of just trivial it's
something that there's a
misunderstanding and like you said we're
not here to belittle them just so to
understand them Etc inshallah